I returning now to a breaking news story
and Britain France and Germany saying
that they are launching a dispute
mechanism against Iran for breaking its
commitment under the 2015 nuclear deal
the u.s. of course had pulled out of the
deal and now the European saying they'll
trigger the dispute mechanism which
means that the United Nations Security
Council will now decide whether the
jcpoa 2015 year iran nuclear deal which
was agreed between Tehran and several
world powers including Europeans and
Americans is still alive or dead let's
bring in Dorsett Jabari in Tehran
Forrest dorsa the the nuclear deal I
mean had had been all but dead I mean
there's been so many violations and also
so many issues with this deal what are
we to make of this move by the Europeans
to trigger this dispute mechanism well
this is something that we were hoping
would not happen it's quite a serious
measure taken by the Europeans that are
left in this nuclear deal now what this
means is that there will now be a
commission formed to investigate the
disputes that is ongoing between the
remaining signatories of this deal and
Iran what this means is that the
Europeans feel the Iranians are not
upholding their end of the bargain and
they've actually broken away from the
promises that they made under this deal
the Iranians has said because the United
States withdrew from the deal in May of
2018
the remaining signatories weren't
upholding their end of the bargain
so Iran under certain Articles that was
written into this agreement started
scaling back its commitment they started
reducing their commitments to the
nuclear deal from May of last year and
every step they took they said we'll
give the Europeans 60 days to respond to
our concerns and then we can go back to
our initial agreement and we'll go back
to those requirements the limitations
set under the nuclear deal what this
dispute mechanism does is it sets up as
chain of events which begins with a
joint investigative Commission formed by
the
foreign ministers of these signatories
of this deal to investigate the problems
that they're having basically the
signatories of this deal are in dispute
with each other so this commission will
be set up they will have two 15-day
periods to come up with an resolution
now if they can't if there is no
agreement reached between Iran and the
remaining European signatories because
China and Russia are not part of this
dispute resolution then they go to the
United Nations Security Council the
Security Council then has another 30-day
period
to investigate these issues if the
Security Council does decide that
there's no way to resolve these
differences they will decide they will
have a vote in the Security Council on
the jcpoa and decide whether or not to
stop snapback those Security Council
sanctions on Iran that were lifted since
the signing of this deal in 2015
reminders dorsa of the commitments that
Iran had made and some of these
commitments they've scaled back on since
this deal was done well the main thing
that Iran agreed to under this deal was
to slow down its nuclear activities its
nuclear program to limit certain parts
of their nuclear program in the country
and also have more transparency with the
international community and the
International Atomic Energy organization
for inspectors to come and go without
any advance notice to open up all the
nuclear facilities to inspections under
the agreement and also to limit certain
reactors the main one being the four DOE
nuclear facility near home this was
where Iran is capable of enriching
uranium at 20% levels this facility
under the nuclear deal became a research
facility only so they stopped enriching
uranium at this facility this is one of
two facilities in Iran that has the
capabilities to enrich uranium
Nats hands near Isfahan is the other one
this facility for doe became a research
facility until
November of last year in in May the
president Hassan rouhani said we're
going to start reducing our commitments
they started with increasing in
centrifuges increasing the number of the
amount of heavy water they're allowed to
keep in the country so step by step they
reduce their commitments and went back
to what they were initially doing in
their nuclear program the most
significant step they took was in
November their fourth step that was to
restart the four dole nuclear facility
to enrich uranium now they said they
weren't they're not up to 20% at the
moment there are around five percent
enrichment levels but this was the main
concern of the international community
this facility is one of the main
concerns because it has the capabilities
of enriching up to 20 percent but in
November Iran said that's it we're going
back to what we were initially doing at
this facility it is no longer going to
be a research facility and they are
going to restart enriching at fordo and
they did the president Hassan rouhani is
in charge of making decisions about
Iran's nuclear program within a body
called the supreme national security
council this is a very important party
that is made up of various different
heads of governments they've said that
they're ready to go back to their
commitments until when they see the
European signatories go back to their ok
door so we're gonna leave it there for
now thank you very much for that from
Tehran and the e use diplomatic chief
has just spoken to reporters and says
the goal of the dispute mechanism is not
to impose new sanctions on Iran but
rather find solutions